[Music]
my name is Matt Vogel I am one of the
Muppet performers on Sesame Street
I play Big Bird hello there Big Bird
here with my friend the sheep on Sesame
Street there are basically three kinds
of puppets there are rod puppets like
Elmo there are live hand puppets like
Cookie Monster and then there are
puppets that you wear like big bird or
Snuffy
I wear ridiculous orange pants with
giant feet they put the puppet over my
head goes down to about my knees my
right hand is up in the air inside the
head and that moves the mouth of Big
Bird and that makes me talk like big
bird like this inside the head there's
also a little a little trigger on my
pinky that moves Big Bird's eyelids up
and down then my left hand is inside Big
Bird's left wing and the right wing
there is a mana fill that goes up
through his neck and down into that left
hand when I move my live hand up the
right hand goes down and and vice versa
we'll need two hands to pick up a proper
or hold something a right hand performer
will come in put their hand in the wing
and that's how we do it
and then on the outside like four
thousand turkey feathers that have been
meticulously graded and steamed and dyed
Big Bird is the heaviest puppet in the
world no I don't know I don't know how
much he weighs my name is Ryan Dylan and
I am the muppet performer for Elmo so
Elmo is a standard hand and rod Muppet
meaning that my hand controls him like
this it's very important when your
puppeteering in this style to not flap
the top of your mouth because we don't
do that as humans so you drop the jaw on
all the syllables its hands are worked
by what we call arm rods
there's use two metal rods with dowels
in them and I tend to control them on my
own but sometimes I'll have an assistant
performer coming in help for more
difficult scenes there's a number of
ways where we have a character pick
things up sometimes you can use magnets
insert them in the palm of the hand
Cookie Monster Ernie telly they can pick
things up with no problem because they
have live hands Elmo Abby those
characters are a little trickier there's
wire in the arms but we can't actually
move the fingers most puppets that are
built in this television style are built
with very specific materials the main
material being foam rubber after they've
been built with the foam they will then
be covered in fake fur which is what
Elmo is covered in Elmo doesn't have
eyelids his eyes are attached in his
head with a wooden dowel so that if you
move that dowel with your finger he can
do this sort of funny look with his eyes
and it's sort of a vague sort of
emotional expression that he can give
and so he doesn't really have a
mechanism necessarily but he does have
that which eye I use more than I
probably should
what are we gonna do we both want to do
see a print tonight my name is Martin
Robinson I play snuffleupagus it's a
cross between a puppet and a costume
character you climb inside there's a
zipper in his midsection sorry if I'm
destroying any illusions I put my feet
in the two front feet and the brilliant
guy behind me whose name is Brian Young
who's my partner in Snuffy
have to kind of stretch so I have to
lean slightly forward he has to lean
slightly back so that there's no swag
I've actually got it rigged so that most
of the weight is on my legs I've never
heard my back doing it I work his mouth
with my left hand
oh bird what are we gonna do now and the
eyes are worked with my right hand look
left look right thank you how do you
work the snuffle it's a curved piece of
PVC with a bike handle it's very
complicated I'm Lesley Carrara Rudolph
my main character is the fairy Abby
Cadabby but doing all kinds of things
she reminds me of my dog you know the
way she looks on screen she's always
excited and happy that she has her hands
and rods but she also has wings so she
has like this little tube that has a Mac
that you rock back and forth and that
makes her wings go when I first got her
they thought originally that they were
gonna use this motor it was loud it was
uncomfortable and they said yeah that
doesn't work we perform above her head
we look down at a monitor in order to
see what direction are puppets going and
I remember Dave goals said to me and he
was right
he says it's gonna be about seven years
before you really know what you're doing
looky here laughter and tell a joke I'm
Frankie Cordero and I play Rudy not
Sesame Street I describe him as he's
definitely super curious which gets him
into trouble sometimes as well but he
definitely always means well this is
gonna be his third season coming up that
I'm doing so he's still a little new the
puppet itself is a pretty basic Muppet
style puppet with the moving mouth and
the rod hands but it still took some
getting used to on Sesame Street a lot
of times around the floor on
roley's obviously these characters are
rather small compared to people so we've
got several characters on screen but
then we've got six or seven bodies down
below because we sometimes have assists
as well that come in to do right hands
or winds or different things
so there's a little bit more
choreography going on down below
compared to what you actually see on
screen at its essence every character is
the person performing it you take a
piece of your personality and you've
blow that up and that kind of becomes
the essence of the character so Big Bird
for me is this kind of wide-eyed every
child that just wants to play and have
fun a little bit of me when I was
younger but then also a mixture of two
nieces of mine as well as my one of my
cats when I started doing Elmo I had
been with Sesame Street for a number of
years doing right handing under the
guidance of the performer before me who
played Elmo so I started to pick up the
mannerisms of the character just being
in the studio I have under studied under
Caroll Spinney for over 20 years it does
take a very long time to feel like you
are the character we have this thing
that some of us say like it's it's being
able to take the character out of the
glass box and just set it free so for me
for Abby I got to create her style
there's little moments that we're always
discovering that brings her to life you
know are excited the way she shakes all
that is organic to the heart and the
exploration and sometimes it looks awful
and sometimes it looks great no matter
what we do we're mirroring humanity in
some really important incredibly
effective way which is strange for a
snuffleupagus and a worm but that's
exactly what we do there are five of us
here right yes so but if we were sitting
on the floor and trying to do our
puppets we have arms all over this you
have to get it right I mean it going
recline